alors tu vois quelque chose certain
temps non non non rien du tout mais
écoute c'est impossible ouvre grand les
yeux et dit - exactement ce que tu vois
aubin enfin je te le répète pour la
dixième fois je vois la route les arbres
du petit bois et les fleurs dans les
champs c'est tout ce n'est pas rien du
tout sans frein enfin en tout cas c'est
rien de ce qui nous intéresse puis à
bord occupes toi de ce qui te regarde
ratatat intense hayek si si je me vois
ils arrivent ils approchent vite vite
vite par attention préparons nous à un
genou près depuis plus d'une maman je
t'aime toi tais toi le voilà
casimir léonard facteurs entraidons
carabins mes pauvres amis un samouraï et
les soucis même temps une chanson une
chanson vous savez aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas le coeur à chanter la chanson une
chanson mon champion puisque je vous dis
que je n'ai pas le coeur à la mêlée une
chanson ou une chanson qui nous en font
bon après tout je crois que vous avez
raison ça va me chasser les soucis un
bon je vais vous la chanter à les voilà
dans leur musique
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson géographe
j'aurais pu même être chaud très
j'aurais pu un tout petit bassin au
viseur ou mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le roi
d'orthographe
je suis l'ami des jolies
l'amoureux des phrases et ses lego
je les emporte sur mon
sous la manche ont voté
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier pas son ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chantre
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs comprise
pour mécanographe mais j'ai choisi
d'être acteur car je suis le roi dans
l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures gay et charmante quand
l'orthographe fait respecter cela
m'enchante
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson bouger au gras
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivé heures confie
ce fou mais cale au bras mais j'ai
choisi d'être prêt
je suis le roi leur programme
dès que commence ma tournée
tout le long du chemin je change
les gens guette mon arrivée cela
montchamp
[Musique]
je vais plus à ton pied zingueur veniez
masson rouge et au gras
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mégalo
mais je choisis d'être pack performant
et je choisis des tracteurs pour sur lui
mais j'ai choisi d'être
[Musique]
immergé vous mes bons amis vous avez un
jour cela m'a rendu ma bonne humeur
mâchoire vivre allez j'ai tout de même
un sérieux problème à vous confier à et
bien nous vous écoutons
mais je n'ai pas peur bon ben figurez
vous qu'au mon chef a décidé de faire
une vente de timbres poste le jour de la
fête de l'île aux enfants à saint lys
unis pratiquement vise en effet à
a pour sûr d'accord seulement voilà le
problème j'ai des timbres qui viennent
de plusieurs pays et j'ignore de quel
pays viennent ça mais il ya sans doute
des des dessins succès timbre à
poursuivre oui
nous allons vous dire ça je vais
chercher les enfants qui jouent dans mon
jardin auront compris que pour sue c'est
une bonne idée ça ht allez-vous près
d'oyonnax
le facteur un
monstre alice abbat voilà mes enfants le
problème c'est donc de savoir de quel
pays proviennent ces timbres enfin
plutôt le dessin qui représente le times
alors celui là c'est là ce que vous
savez de quel pays il vient
faf fasciste comme un gardon fâcheux
nabawi à treize mois de new york mais
c'est pas nous y sommes enfin si ces
américains ces sécheresses à cette
amérique alors aux lyonnais celui là un
bon ben alors ça fait nathalie
aussi weeds à la ville est ce que tu
sais la ville non moi je voulais léonard
la cia notamment
son choix ce coup à présent c'est un
celui ci un tel entretien par dont
l'angleterre quelle ville selon et
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une grande
tendu là c'est la grande forme du zx des
big men
sur lui on a bien su reprendre ses
complices il ya une celui-ci maintenant
1 est ce que vous savez
s'il est ce que c'est ça
ou tel pays
léonard c'est ça l'amérique du sud
l'amérique du sud bon bah c'est le
brésil brésil brésil le brésil pas mal
ça c'est moi qui ai trouvé
bon je note dans ma tête bon celui-ci
maintenant tu le vois bien la grèce bon
et elle vise
c'est ça un exacto pour trouver le
premier enfant et celui là vous savez
alors alors alors léonard
mais lorsque tu as tu rigoles écoulée or
ils sont bien plus difficiles tu vas
pouvoir trouver celui là là il n'a pas
trouvé un leonard leo non c'est bon ça
pouvait dès lors alors là je te
comprends pas comment toi tu est
incollable sur les employés sur celui ci
tu trouves pas justement c'est rêver
enfin ce n'est quand même pas marre
pente si quelqu'un a arraché une page de
mon catalogue
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]